all right hello everybody i'm gonna do a
kind of uh
experiment today i've been watching some
cool reaction videos
and i have one i want to share with you
i watched the beginning
of this video with sam and uh
really delightful really interesting
insights into
the nidorf bishop e2 variation and
let me just introduce this game and
what's going on here
this game was played at the 2010 us
championship between
uh hess gm hess and gm shanklin
who was changing was black in this
position
and he's talking about this as an
example
of a loss and this is part of the u.s
chess
school that's run by gregory shahada and
is now being hosted
by uh kostyakovsky and chess
dojo and so let me just tell you what's
happening is the interesting dynamic
is the class is really for the top
kids in the united states and twice a
week now it's this amazing thing that's
happened during covid
we've got different instructors coming
in some week like myself
and then oftentimes we have some super
gm like
sam and in this first
new revitalization of the us chess
school greg wanted us all to prevent
to present some game that
hurt us and that we hopefully learn from
and so i found the beginning part of
this lecture fascinating but i'm going
to start here because
this is where i'm going to say the game
kind of departs
from the opening and robert is about to
play e5 in this position
and i just want to give you my live
thoughts as
we're going on okay here we go
ahead and threw e5 this does not work
there's no doubt in my mind this does
not work
uh during the game there is no doubt
either but we have to keep things under
control i did to a point but then i lost
control
at the wrong moment so how do we proceed
with black here
i don't think we take this one a lot of
times you take on e5 and the sicilian
one white goes e5 but i don't think we
want to go to this one
at least not yet it looks very dangerous
let's just say e5 doesn't look right
because now the bishop on b7 is an
absolute monster
and uh yeah but
i think one of the cool things about e5
is what hess
is doing is he's realizing that the
trend of the position hasn't gone his
way
and is he is now changing the nature of
the game
with this move so i think that's where
it gets really interesting
and right shanklin is now gonna not
gonna react
well to it first instinct is like knight
fd5
or maybe knight h5 also could be
possible
but knight h5 you always run into
trouble
and i should say the kids can't hear
kostya so sometimes costa and
sav are a little bit talking over each
other but kosia is like just watching it
as it's happening so that's why i called
this video
me watching kostya watch sam
hey adrian perelstein with the raid
thank you so much eugene
we are in the middle of a class with gm
sam shankland
who's teaching the us chess school
they're all in their zoom meeting
i'm muted in their meeting but we can we
can listen in
and i can make comments and give you
guys
my thoughts you can see how hard the
classes i mean i
i don't know i think i'm batting at like
50 right now
if that okay so people are mostly
getting this
um i certainly don't think there's
anything wrong with a move like knight
fd5
uh i suspect black is doing quite well
here i mean
given my knowledge of shivanigan
structures now that
when white goes f4 e5 if you can safely
ignore it like this
and without letting white get f5 next it
probably is going to be pretty
reasonable for black
indeed let's say let's i don't know we
take this knight takes d5
like bishop d4 or something and black
can play
knight takes up for feels like a bit
much
after rook takes f4
take on e5 and then um
some kind of rook h4 or something it
feels like a bit much but maybe it's
playable
but even just bishop g7 i mean how bad
can this be it seems very comfortable
for black to me
uh his king is totally safe and i think
that his pieces are more active
the knight on b3 is pretty bad black's
bishop on b7 is going to be fantastic
and
i don't think you have to worry much
about getting checkmated here
so that certainly would be fine but as a
couple people have pointed out the
tactics are in black's favor
um he can take on e5 but here this is
what i'm talking about
about having knight takes d3 hanging in
the reserve i think this is a very good
moment for it right now
right when we know that our queen is
about to leave the c file
is a perfect moment to uh take white's
bishop pair from him and compromise the
queenside structure
so um
here uh queen e5 was possible but knight
d3 i think is stronger we got takes and
that takes and the point as a couple
people have pointed out
is that the strategic is that the
tactical shot bishop d4 is well met by
queen h5
during the game i just assumed this is
what robert had missed and i thought oh
okay i'm just going to basically win
this game and look got a
bishop pair a better structure healthy
upon up but
i became a little bit worried when
robert just immediately took on b6
he just didn't think about it for half a
second i was like okay wait i mean
according to my understanding here i was
like wait i have a better structure a
healthy bishop parrot you're going off
and taking a queen side pawn like
is this really a thing but that is sort
of diamond wood knight a5 is coming
and it's actually pretty annoying to
deal with now again rest assured this
does not work
black is clearly better but he really
needs to remain focused
and punish white for what he's done with
accurate play this went bad
very very quickly from for me from here
yeah now the first mistake i
made here was trying to complicate the
game or having an idea of playing into a
complicated look at that beautiful
bishop
the move i made was actually not
fundamentally bad the attitude behind it
was so
let's see what people can come up with
oh boy
oh boy it's like i really don't like
that another i think that's good big
boys are going to arise
so bishop d4 i think sam mentioned we
always have queen
h5 as a counter we're okay
so rick ab8 kind of feels like first
instinct so knight a5 we can keep our
bishop on the diagonal
you're i don't get it white wants to
threaten knight f5 do you not care
yeah or rook a c8 or even rook no no
or kca also very possible there were
cases because the rook's right
henry that is the best move hangs a
little bit
rick ac8 feels like the move
a5 is also possible i was thinking about
a5
no guys i did not play it but a5 maybe
knight b5 likes
so a few people have pointed out i just
want to say
this position looks so bad for white
so incredibly bad but one thing i know
is i played the sicilian for years and
it's just really dangerous man even like
yeah so even in this nasty position
white is going to somehow drum up
something
it seems very implausible the black
structure is so
solid and honestly it feels like black
it's hard to imagine for me here the
move
that ruins it for black
it's really hard for me to see it rook
ac8
maybe rook 8b8 you know
maybe yeah like someone may kosu
mentioned a5 i don't really like a5 too
much but
you know it all seems just massive
massive for white the move
uh rook ac8 which is best this gets this
rook to a nice open file hey
clears the air from the bishop and you
know you keep it cool
about it there's no need to fear bishop
d4 once more queen h5 is good and
there's no nothing to be scared of
and here i think black is clearly better
yes as a couple people
i call people had other moves in minds
but i didn't think much of them
um someone said bishop d6 but
uh bishop d6 i think knight a5 is an
issue and then
knight c4 is the threat's knight b7 is
the threats and this feels like things
have gone wrong
somebody else suggested knight d5 but as
soon as this knight moves away
now bishop d4 is an issue i think you
probably have to go queen h5 which is a
bad sign because if you play
i don't know what else queen d6 this is
not going to feel good
um but after queen h5 and say knight a5
i'm quite worried that this end game
will get very bad very fast
um once you probably have to do
something like this but still this
bishop cannot
come to d5 on pain of c4 and well white
will take but take back the bishop pair
and retain his potentially better
structure here it's probably not the end
of the world for black but i don't love
it
um but yeah rook aca was best and that
was clearly better for black but me i
went for rook a b8
no i calculated an interesting variation
here
uh anybody see the variation i might
have calculated
because this move looks like it blunders
something
oh bishop c7 okay okay here we go bishop
c7 takes knight d5
and what did sam want
just knight takes d5 oh probably just
knight takes d5
tacos i mean you think the same button
will have pointed out white has an
understand move here
all right so i'm going to show you guys
the variation i calculated
what i calculated was bishop c7 queen
takes c7 now if knight d5 knight takes
d5 just wins
and discussion uh so
but 94. and what i had calculated was
take take
take uh take rook d3
and now i am hitting the queen as well
as mid on the back rank and following
let's say queen g4 i go
bishop f5 queen e2 rookie g8
white is forced back to c1 and at bare
minimum bishop g7 we'll come and take
some material i think rook d2 is dang
that's pretty cool we will get some
position like this and maybe will say
this
but it's not going to be pretty his king
is in massive danger the pieces are so
much better than uh than white's queen
there's no doubt about it so uh this is
what i had anticipated was going
i just say like that rook ac8 move is
easy for us passers to play because it
just looks natural
and rook ab8 of course is trying to just
end the game
so rook aba definitely you know like the
tactical way
because all those pieces are hanging on
the b file like when you
say especially if you study with a
computer a lot that you're going to be
drawn to move like rook aba
to happen and ryan is saying it's
impractical to calculate all this that
is correct especially when you realize
that you've made a mistake
bishop c7 came on the board uh-oh and at
first i was confused like wait really
because i thought this was all
straightforward and then brian
what a hero okay always be
wary of automatic moves i calculated
rook f6 rook d3 and it ends up in
black's favor why to play anyway
why to play and win oh my god careful
guys so far two people have given me
horrible moves
slow down just one move and it's
resigned three people have given bad
news
finally someone got it right
yeah good job this is
what wow and black can resign
immediately uh the game is immediately
over i don't think rook takes up seven
was working for those who are suggesting
i just wrote takes d3 or something
we're bishop f5 i don't i don't get it i
don't get the point i mean
what if i take this one even take in
here
oh man i have missed queen edge for what
have i done
hmm okay
this is but that's a live by the sword
die by the sword thing you know
like it might have worked out and you're
playing with heavy calculation
you're gonna miss something like that
yeah
but it's actually it's it's a good
example of like right you missed
something
and now we're gonna have to figure out
some way to try to save the game
the white structure is still so poor
that even if we lose the exchange it's
not necessarily the end
um
and it shows like those kinds of
calculation decisions
yeah that's where that's where it's
going to be made
especially if you play in this way and
especially if you play the night off
the most instructive moment of the game
to air is human
people make mistakes i made a mistake i
blundered queen h4
black is still good here but you need to
get back to work
and calculate and improve variation this
is very important had i done this i
think it's very likely i win this game
hmm we need to correct the mistake we
just just always
not give up just because we made a
mistake i played queen g5 here went down
in exchange for not nearly enough
compensation and lost without much of a
fight
uh we can get away with taking on c7
but we need to improve on this variation
we need to calculate well
here we go guys we got this
queen c7 if there's not one thing you
guys think
in this class when you make a mistake
especially a tactical one and you have a
move that you're really hoping you could
get away with
and then your opponent is pointing out
to you that you can't
then the next thing you should be
thinking is i missed something can i
improve on this variation before giving
up and
bailing out to some you know lousy
position after queen g5
so you're saying queen c7 is good we
just have to make it work so queen c7
knight e4
bishop e4 rook c7 bishop f5
you can do that rook takes f5
ef i guess that ghost is right i don't
see anything else but
three queen takes f6 that's the queen
takes f6 still a big problem though
slow down guys this is hard if you guys
are giving me an answer in like
20 seconds i you're almost certainly
wrong
this is
[Music]
like so far a lot of people have given
me some really silly variations and
that's normal if you're answering this
this quickly
slow down especially if you've just made
a mistake now i cannot force you guys
into the same frame of mind i was in
like oh no what did i just do in round
one of the us championship
uh but try as hard as you can
slow down find the way don't spew some
nonsense at me in one minute
if you if it takes you five ten minutes
to find the way that's absolutely fine
accuracy is what matters here okay guys
time to calculate
time to calculate 794.
knight takes f6 a big threat right so we
feels like we have to take this knight i
just don't see even queen takes c1
knight takes f6 we get mated
white can improve upon that variation
somewhere but you're on a good you're on
a good start
take 94 we take with knight
rick takes c7
really seeing a move there
you drive then you're just gonna be down
in exchange in the ending that's not
okay
queen c7 the response is 94.
oh man that's the hard one
then probably bishop takes e4 rook takes
c7 so the line that that sam was giving
was
queen c7 knight e4 bishop takes e4
rook takes c7 rook takes b3 and then
that doesn't work
because of queen h4
knight d5 is not working uh because
after knight t5 i can just play knight
takes d5 rook c7 knight takes c7
and then black will have rook and two
miners julian that is correct but white
has an improvement somewhere along the
line that you're going to need to find
and
see where he can do better oh man
oh man and then have another one freddy
yeah david i was thinking the same queen
c784 takes
rook takes bishop f5 but then what to do
on
that yeah so we could take this and then
instead of
here rook takes b3 we can switch the
move or and start with bishop f5
there we go buddy uh and this changes
things dramatically so there's a lot of
people ghost is so happy but in a lot of
ways it was like the one thing we could
do
and white structure continues to be so
terrible
that yeah the gods are a little bit on
our side even if we have
blundered it a little bit here we'll
have pointed out in the event of rook
takes a five he takes so five what is
busted
uh because rookie one is coming and you
will need to stop that somehow rook
jake's b3 will come and black will have
way too much material for the queen but
of course white is going to play queen
h4
and what do we do now that's what that's
what i was saying
that's what i was saying okay
yeah max got it bishop
d6 yes people are getting this knife d5
once we're here it's easy to say
and at this point uh black has two
pieces for a queen but he will get a
third and
uh i think at very high depths the
computer is able to like with extremely
precise play
managed to equalize with light in this
line it's like takes and now
i think it's g4 and um thank you guinea
pig
rook takes b3 is going to be a perpetual
but rook b4
is i think a better try and there's some
likes here
here yikes takes another what i think is
it this one takes
jesus ricochet is coming and
the computer found some weird sequence
of only moves to hold this with light in
practice i think a human is very likely
to lose
wow even a very strong one at that
okay that's pretty intense man going
back
what i did wrong this game was
two major mistakes one
when i got a little bit rattled by this
move bishop to xb6 which
you know a yeah sure i had barely even
considered but also is not a wildly
intimidating move
i immediately aimed to complicate the
game and change the course of things
one that was a practical mistake i
should have kept it simple with a move
like rook ac8 when black has
to my eyes a very nice advantage um
but two and i think the bigger one is
that upon realizing that i had missed a
key resource
that changed the nature of the game
immediately and uh
and would leave me with a lost position
when i in a line where i thought that i
was okay
i didn't put enough effort into trying
to make it work anyway
and i didn't uh i didn't correct myself
and instead he went for some very
nebulous compensation and
essentially agreed to being an exchange
down um
look there i want to say that the
loss of the exchange in this position
it's not like he's without compensation
definitely has compensation because
white's pawns are terrible
and yada yada so it's like you see queen
g5 and you might tell yourself
i'm i'm sad that i missed this bishop c7
move
but on the other hand unless white comes
up with something pretty special
i think after this bishop b8 rook b8
then you gotta still believe in
in black i mean we're gonna see
obviously white found something but just
intuitively it still looks like black is
doing all right there will be times
when you make mistakes that are big
enough that they should just cost you
the game and all you can do is look for
practical chances
but before you make that decision that
you should just accept
basically a lost position and um
and then and just look for practical
tries and try to make your opponent's
life difficult
you should check if there's no resources
left in
the line you originally calculated yes i
missed something after queen takes c7
but queen takes c7
still worked and if i had instead of
giving up gone to uh
gone to try to make queen take c7 work
all the same and improve upon the
variation that i had previously had that
didn't work
i think the result of this game
certainly would have changed i
definitely don't think i would have lost
it's very likely i would have won
so instead i played queen g5 and
i don't believe i have nearly enough
compensation for an exchange here but
uh one of the things that made robert
and i guess continue to make
make robert the player he is is uh when
he gets a
situation like this he controls the
counter play very well what does white
do now
it's still not that trivial to win the
game
um look at that bishop on b7
look at both those bishops it's still
amazing for you like queen jeans
people are giving me queen g3 that feels
very wrong yeah weakening the structure
mg3 i can like take it and then
knight h5 or knight g4 shift d6 is
coming
yeah i thought bad news i think what's
already worse
careful 94 somebody says i don't
understand that knight takes e4 and
bishop takes e4 we'll leave black
uh pretty good position i think
i think we got to get the nine on b3
back into play yeah something like
knight b4 buddy
knight 24 is the best move f3 next
nice alright he kicked black's quinn out
of the way and sort of used tonight as a
glorified meat shield on the long
diagonal so i went for knight g4 trying
to get some counter play what does
did he say a glorified meat shield
[Laughter]
a glorified meat shield now he's
moaning about his position but honestly
i don't know if it's that bad you know
now obviously he's worried about knight
takes e6 and yada yada
but i still i don't know you know now
i don't see it as bad as what he's
saying
uh a rod you got shanky'd
oh knight f3 knight of two check gotta
be careful guys
might have three knives f2 is an evil
trick
or even takes time no i assume you mean
the non-stupid one but yes that's
correct
and queen g3 is a thought andy got
shankied
yeah you gotta move our rook hey he got
shanky
yes
yeah you know the practical game no you
gotta think black has good compensation
i mean
i don't know what he does after queen g3
but it's still
it's still beautiful those beautiful
bishops brian he didn't even just got
himself shanky he got himself
mated yes henry well spotted
yeah people are getting this don't
blonder knight f2 guys
some kind of if knight e4 or knight f3
or whatever at some point knight f2 is
going to land and that's the end
or uh rip takes f7 queen c1 was there if
knight f3 there's knight f2 directly or
queen c1 first whatever you want
this knight f2 move is a problem be sure
to deal with it
as some people have correctly found
rooksy one hence
following bishop c5 uh knight f3
queen f5 uh what should i do now
oh man all these people getting shankied
australian
94 no i don't think you want to do 94.
yes then i don't think that's a great
one it's probably
okay-ish but
can't you just do like d4 can't you do
d4
95 maybe 95
goes to you out of your mind buddy 95
net f2 check i think
yeah you can't do that business takes f2
queen takes out i think people are
getting this now
i have to be very careful here guys a
lot of people gave me another five i'd
have to check that's not a good way to
lose a chess game no
um
f2 check next as well which also should
win for black or at least reach the
basically winning end game
um a couple of people are saying rookie
two
feels weird but you can just play h5 or
something even
g8 or something
yeah you're just saying 93 oh yeah 93
what am i talking about 93
this should just take something right
taking gf5 or something and
starting to lose control once this
knight once this pawn gets to f4 i mean
how good are wetz rooks really
um but uh
there's some gorgeous variation here i'm
trying to remember that i can't off the
top of my head
um oh yeah okay no but queen g3 was
played
all right uh queen g3 is best it gets
off of all these threats
okay rook d8 uh one last move for white
what do we do now
i mean you can calculate from here to
the end of the game let's put it that
way
from here to the end of the game
arnold got shanked
the trick to not getting shanky is to
just not offer
a suggestion that's right gaucia
don't suggest anything what is getting
shanked it's falling from my tricks
and losing to me in a position you
shouldn't have
uh soon arc that is correct
a couple of people are giving me h3 i
don't think that's great after knight e3
yeah don't don't allow 93 bro 27 people
are giving
yeah all right people are mostly getting
this now um
so okay i don't know if you have to be
careful someone's giving me a queen h4
this feels very wrong
no no and then if not g5 i have knight
f2
yeah no dude this is the ends blackest
one
um well yeah people have pointed this
out
uh d4 is best and after bishop d6 95
white has it all under control following
bishop e5 to e5 queen h5 and 94 i had to
resign here there's nothing else
uh you resigned a very beautiful loss
for me i still had hopes that robert
would play this lovely move which a few
of you wanted to do
that is definitely on my radar let's put
it that way
what does happen now well he does have a
no
why does this not work for white because
it looks pretty good at first glance
man oh man i think you're gonna play
bishop f3 i don't get it there's queen
takes b7 and then
what is face up
has to not get shanked in this game
that's true
it'd be real easy to fall for this queen
c7 so
hmm
that's hard for me man i don't know yeah
black wins somehow
how the hell still like
rook d3 queen takes b7
i'm going to be getting a rook takes d3
and knight f2 this is not enough
taken this is a piece up
is it a brilliancy i mean i guess in
theory it could have been if robert had
blundered but he didn't
i mean he played better um but it's i
don't even think it's that crazy but
what do we do here
bishop to xf3 brian i don't get it queen
takes the check and then rick takes f3
back isn't that just a
broke up oh i think i get it knight f2
rook takes bishop takes queen d8 king g7
and i'm threatening queen takes f3
i think i think
oh
is that for real or is it memorex it
might not be right because if you have
to ask me about this like if you give me
a move with a question mark at the end
it's almost certainly wrong you will
know if it's right
oh man oh man
some people are giving me a queen d3
i'll take c5 though
or rook do you want even
no rip down there's not f2 but just
queen c5
i'm having trouble i'm having trouble
and you drop a rook on d8 man that's a
big deal
that's a full coconut
man oh man crying what are you missing
buddy
what well i'm drawing such a blank here
guys
i'm like looking for everything there is
a few more minutes to solve it
uh whatever three doesn't work
mr shahadi had in mind next queen d3 is
out rook takes d3
is out
wow dude this one's hard
i don't i don't nintendo this one i'll
tell you
i don't know oh man what a bummer
robertson i didn't do this either
it's pretty hardcore
oh man i'm not seeing it
hmm really tough man
really tough i think jr magnus my lion
queen f3 doesn't work because he just
plays rook e4
like knight f2 rook takes bishop takes
queen takes a rook and uh
and you know rook e4 blocking my bishop
the only thing i'd come up with but i
don't
i don't see how that works
it's really impressive that robert
didn't fall for whatever this thing is
dang this is next level man
this is next level come on guys you can
do it
queen takes f3 i think the same problem
queen takes d
i'm noticing here there's another
resource f3
etc
but no it's still it's not it's still
okay i think
what for queen d3 he said queen takes c5
yeah queen c5 is the end after that
oh you guys i'm feeling humiliated
yeah now roger i don't think that's good
enough like he'll take back and he
should be in good shape
all right one more minute guys oh
man this is really tough man
oh maybe just queen h5 guys
queen h5 go see i don't think so bro
and then if queen takes b7 we'll go rook
takes d3
and we just want to take on f3 no bro
because he's always got h3 no it's
duckweed h5
bro you're just guessing like everybody
else coach
what he's saying buddy it's not queen h5
dude so can you believe
this is what i had in mind oh knight f2
okay that's what i first thought
show me how to stop queen f3 rookie four
that was my thing i couldn't figure out
rookie four
ninety-four i don't think was good and
there's this one notes oh man
once those rookie four did i blunder
this or something
or do i not remember the lines from 10
years well maybe
maybe i got it right buddy maybe i just
flushed you guys maybe i got it right i
was like rookie four
dude rookie four yeah ricky parker
definitely remembered i had a big
thought after queen system i saw this
immediately
trying to use stocks exercise though i
mean
calculate a lot of uh it was prying
again
brian here oh this was right but here
attacks track
yeah rookie four bro rookie four that's
again yeah we all stopped looking
forward this isn't working yeah we all
saw this queen takes f3
maybe i'm just gonna cheat because we're
running short of time and greg wanted to
do things i thought there was supposed
to be some trick here i thought all
right let's see stock this is
pull it up stock face full of nonsense
cheat cheat
what do you know i just wasted all
y'all's time of finding a win that
wasn't there
nice nice that's so hilarious
dude because i was like i was like oh
yes he was a real genius not to play
queen c7 man he saw some deep trick
he saw some deep trick but there was no
deep trick
honestly it was kind of that was even
though he was wrong even though he
misled us
that was still pretty amazing we got
calculations
for it everything is good really i must
have confused this variation with
another line
there was there was definitely a line
where this worked for black
huh i can't remember how it happens
uh this is largely the um this is
largely the irrelevance phase i mean i
had been
i had missed my chance and at this point
white has more than one way to win and
what robert chose was certainly good
enough
um but uh and i'd still want to say
like if i was playing this position
i'd be worried and everything but yeah
there's parts of it i'd still believe i
had
good chances and maybe even knight g4
you had some way to keep the
just keep the game going because as long
as you keep the game going
you know and this also this rook d8 move
was just like
inviting all kinds of stuff
you know yeah anyhow
um that being in mind greg if you're
listening there
uh you said you wanted me to end that
for an hour what
uh what comes next yeah sam that was uh
all right guys that was brilliant um i
really enjoyed that i encourage you to
watch
the beginning because it was like a
really master class
in the opening and uh
yeah we're doing this cool thing uh
along with greg jahada
the dojo doing the us chess school i
myself
uh got to go to the what was then the
u.s chess school
taught at the marshall chess club
i was like that was a long time ago my
friends that was the 1980s but it was
one of the highlights of my youth back
then we didn't have the internet so it
was just like that was the only kind of
study i had and especially cool now
because i'm reading john donaldson's
book
about bobby fischer and of course so
much
of us chess history has taken place at
the marshall
then later i played at the marshall and
then amazingly i had a chance to play at
the manhattan chess club which has long
been defunct i played the under 16
championship
way back in the day there anyways now
i'm just going off
digressing but that's where hess came up
new york city chess culture
um anyways just talking about the us
chess school
we got a class there going on every
tuesday
and thursday night i believe usually
seven o'clock eastern
six o'clock central so check it out
and i'm gonna be back in just a touch to
talk about
this week's games in chess till then
bye-bye